so yesterday I talked about the death of
Colin Powell and we talked about the
political side of it Colin Powell a
republican who yes in his later years
spoke out against anti-muslim rhetoric
and condemned the xenophobia and the
nonsense of Donald Trump and Trump's
followers was not a trump supporting
Republican but also was one of the most
Sinister figures in the sale of the Iraq
War to the American people and the
International Community with faulty
intelligence back in 2003 and we looked
at clips of that and we talked about the
political and we also talked about the
medical Colin Powell was vaccinated he
was 84 years old died of coveted
complications and I mentioned yesterday
that many anti-vaxxers would use this
and point to it and say see there's no
point in getting vaccinated ignoring of
course that the data shows
overwhelmingly that those who die are
not not vaccinated and in addition to
that in the hours after we published
yesterday's clip we learned that Colin
Powell was severely immunocompromised
had Parkinson's as well as a type of
blood cancer called multiple myeloma
which is a big being in treatment for
multiple myeloma is a significant
immunocompromising
circumstance for an individual but it
didn't matter the anti-vax stuff
exploded and it wasn't just the usual
suspect it was even Fox News daytime
reporters pushing this stuff the
anti-vaxxers are foaming at the mouth
using Colin Powell's death while
vaccinated to attack vaccines and to
attack vaccine requirements so we're
going to go over this today
but it's important to say again
Colin Powell was not just a random guy
who was vaccinated and died which can
happen we have significant protection
against severe disease and death from
the vaccines but with a planet of seven
to eight billion people you're going to
have some random seemingly healthy
people who are vaccinated and die that
doesn't mean that we ignore the bigger
statistics but Colin Powell was not just
a random guy he was not even just a
random 84 year old guy who was
vaccinated and died of covid he was an
84 year old
immunocompromised man who died despite
being vaccinated had cancer and had
Parkinson's which significantly affects
your immune system but the anti-vaxxers
want to pretend see the vaccine does
nothing for anyone anybody could die
it's just chance Fox News host will Kane
went on a rant yesterday morning saying
fully vaccinated people are being
hospitalized and dying and it's just we
we can't trust anybody he brought up
coven look this day will be a day for
many things for remembering the man for
remembering the leader that was lost
it's also a day to understand the
implication on everyday Americans and
and the reports are he died from
complications of kova the family has
made a point in their post on Facebook
this morning that Colin Powell was fully
vaccinated and As Americans out there
wonder what lies ahead for them and they
they search and they need truth moving
forward we're seeing data from across
the world we're seeing data from Europe
from the United Kingdom the fully
vaccinated people are being hospitalized
and fully vaccinated people are dying
from covet and here we have a very high
profile example that is going to require
more truth more truth from our
government far now of course there's no
lack of Truth the truth is you're
overwhelmingly less likely to die of
covet if you're vaccinated colon he's
straight up saying this is anecdotal
thinking he's straight up saying this
case shows that we're not getting enough
truth
this case doesn't change the truth which
is the overwhelming uh uh majority of
those who are dying are unvaccinated
even as the country is more and more
vaccinated here's another similar
example this one is from Fox and Friends
playing a similar game there will also
be conversations about the fact that he
was fully vaccinated according to his
family and he died from complications
from covid we are beginning to see
statistics like this grow in frequency
we know that the vaccine does Wane over
time and its ability to protect you from
not just transmission infection but from
severe complications and hospitalization
and obviously death as well we know that
it wanes and we know that it's beginning
to spill over covid into the vaccinated
population again Colin Powell in the
direct age demographic that suffers the
most from complications from covid but I
think everyone watching needs to be
aware of limitations and protections
yeah limitation you are always better
off with the protection of the vaccine
that's the reality and then we'll we'll
follow up on this later
um Fox news reporter John Roberts
tweeted Powell's death was evidence of
the waning efficacy tweeting the fact
that Colin Powell died from a
breakthrough covet infection raises new
concerns about how effective vaccines
are long-term no it doesn't and he
subsequently deleted this tweet he
subsequently deleted this tweet as
Mother Jones has been reporting major
news outlets ran headlines about this
um without acknowledging that Colin
Powell was immunocompromised with
multiple conditions but talking about
him being vaccinated if you're going to
talk about him being vaccinated you've
got to talk about the other side as well
New York Times Colin Powell first black
National Security adviser died at 84 of
covet he was fully vaccinated families
said right but you've you've got to tell
both sides of that MSNBC Colin Powell
dies from covet complications Powell was
fully vaccinated Newsweek former U.S
Secretary of State Colin Powell dies
from coven complications was fully
vaccinated
Colin Powell said in an announcement on
social media he was fully vaccinated if
you're going to do that you should
really say fully vaccinated and severely
immunocompromised it would be
irresponsible not to or skip saying both
skip saying both if you want here's Dr
Zeke Emmanuel
discrediting the idea that Colin
Powell's death
means the vaccines aren't working and he
mentions Powell's risk factors take a
look Colin Powell had three important
risk factors for covet one is his age 84
he's at the very high end and we know
those people are much more vulnerable
second as you point out he had cancer
and third he's a man and men are at much
higher risk of dying especially in his
age category 58 of deaths in those
people 65 to 84 are male even though
they make up a minority of that age
group when it comes to multiple myeloma
it's a cancer of the cells the B cells
in the immune system that produce
antibodies so they don't produce
effective antibodies and they grow and
grow
and when you treat someone uh for
multiple myeloma it does suppress the
immune system so he was
immunocompromised okay so that's as if
we needed more medical experts telling
us what has become obvious over the year
and a half of the pandemic so we are now
going to talk separately about
specifically Tucker Carlson's dog and
pony show that he did in reaction to
this because it's particularly
disastrous and particularly weaponized
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com Pacman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even auto fill the card number
with one click and the payment is taken
out of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a 10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cash back and lets you
create 36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com Pacman